gentlemen uh let's start with
congratulations on the movie um i'm sure
you must be enjoying the positive
reaction and finally starting to screen
it yeah i mean it's great that's why we
make movies you want to share them with
people i mean that was our whole
approach to being filmmakers was we were
film fans growing up and you know the
experiences that we had
watching movies together talking about
them how they made us feel
we now want to give those same feeling
uh
to uh to today's audiences so yes it's
always exciting when you get you get a
film to uh
to the audience i have a lot of things i
wanted to talk about but i'm
specifically gonna ask you about one
thing today so i think a lot of people
don't realize what it really takes to do
an action set piece in a movie of this
scale so if you don't mind let's talk
about the prague sequence in the third
act from this is a big question but
let's see if we can get it into the four
minute bubble of this interview from
inception to on-screen can you sort of
take people through
what it really takes to make a sequence
like that that's about a year yeah or
two you're impossible exceptionally the
on-screen i think was about a year or
two yeah yeah yeah what do you mean
they on screen or i mean like
you understand the question right okay
so like inception isn't like you're
working on the script yeah you're
thinking about this sequence and you
start developing it and then until
getting it on working
then rewrote it again and then started
planning it
uh about a year but some of those stages
is after it's sort of conceived and
written you know like and rewritten and
rewritten like joe was saying you know
then we start to bring it to our
collaborators
and we start to get feedback on it uh
you know we start to work with uh
conceptual artists and we start drawing
pictures to figure out story about it we
can do
we start working with animators and we
do something called previs where we
actually lay the sequence out in an
animated crude animated form
um we start working with our stunt team
and our stunt coordinator uh and we'll
actually start staging things in the
stunt gym uh different sections of the
sequence and we'll shoot it
and we'll sort of revise it as we go
it's a it's a big process of kind of
dreaming up what's possible how do we
make it better testing our ideas and
refining them so that by the time you
get to set because once you get to set
you have to get things right because
it's immensely expensive to be there you
know you're you're sometimes you're
using a huge section of a city that
you're only going to be permitted to use
for a finite period of time so you have
to get things right there's a lot of
pressure so there's many many months of
sort of working a sequence before you're
ready to shoot it then we shoot it and
when we're shooting joe and i love to
review what we've shot put it
visit the editor in the edit room figure
out how we can revise things before
we're done shooting the scene so that we
can make it better then we take it into
the edit room
and it's many many months in the edit
room to get a sequence like maybe
there's three sheets involved sometimes
or
you know but it's it's
yeah it's an endless gig to to bring
something like that to the screen i know
i'm gonna run out of time but in prague
how long did it actually take you to
film that uh six weeks and uh we kept
going back to the square it's something
i think that you know ryan had never
done a movie the scale before and he
trained for months you know he the guy
went through nine action sequences on
this movie uh with a cirque du soleil
level of training you know to be able to
accomplish some of the stuff that he did
in the film
uh and as xanthan mentioned our process
is iterative so you know we would show
up the next day and go hey you know that
thing we've been training you to do for
two months we're throwing that out and
we're gonna do something different and
you know so you know we i think we're
only supposed to shoot this for four
weeks but we kept extending it um
because we kept coming up with new ideas
and and different things that we wanted
to try and get uh get in the can before
we got in the edit room
you